o'malley coming off that career-best
outing these are the season-long numbers
from western and southern it does feel
though lark like he's peaking of late
it really does and i feel that peaking
hasn't necessarily been related to
velocity actually i feel like it's a
pull back from velocity
and more of a
strategic approach to open up the bottom
part of that zone
for the split change
here's ian hat half with three hits and
a homer
last night
this one drilled right field yeah he
likes hitting here all right way out of
here
and hat
liftoff
is 14th
and it is one nothing cubs yeah he likes
it
and that was crushed he's going to go
back in the dugout and says hey listen i
don't know what you guys are going to do
after this but i'm going to stay right
here in cincinnati
take all my at-bats
comebacker andy a sliding pick pops up
the throw was there
well flash the leather if you will indy
that's a great play
adrian sampson yeah and the starting
pitcher for the cubs brought to you by
budweiser this bud's for you
look at his pitch arsenal here 2019 with
the texas rangers sinker slider change
up
an occasional curveball but sinker
slider guy and looking to make the most
out of this opportunity right here his
first start in two years in the big
leagues
2-2
and a swing and a miss struck him out
samson off to a good start adrian gets
him one two three cubs lead one nothing
in the second i think
this one drilled left field that one way
back on its way gone
thermoseal with the home run nice to
have you back in the bigs michael it is
three nothing
that was clobber
absolutely tattoos this ball no doubt in
the upper deck ortega with a man at
second that's robertson torinos
that one flared out into center falling
falls for a hit chirinos around third on
his way to the plate he will score
and it is four nothing
an embarrassment of riches here in the
early going
that one drilled out towards center
field that's gonna touch down and roll
all the way to the fence here comes
ortega around third or take it to the
plate schwindel into second and the cubs
lead it five to nothing
and frank schwendell continues his
torrid pace seventh straight game with
an extra base hit oh the very hot tyler
naquin comes to the plate he is it
safely in seven consecutive games
ortega
slows god
to the netting atop the home bullpen
the renaissance of the reds tyler naquin
reaches new heights
ground ball india sliding stop
offline throw break from second by duffy
he claims third india's slow to get up
still on his knees in the outfield grass
as barnhart backed things up and
gathered the foul ball or the loose ball
i should say in foul ground
jonathan india with the extension right
there and
this guy is grinding through it out
there
he's had some issues physically and
see him grabbing that chest that's an
indication of my shoulder is bothering
me a little bit
that one caught out of the air bodhi
steps on second and it's a double play
bottom can't believe it
good jump by modi to snare that one out
of the air we're heading to the fourth
comes lead
[Music]
maybe a combination of him liking to hit
here and some of the scouting reports
that are being given may not be true
hot shot to first vado's got it
maui works around the two-out hit see if
the reds can get some liqueur luck for
the o when there's a tough matchup and
give the other guy a start so you just
don't get enough
enough opportunity enough repetitions
in there got him looking struck him out
great job by sampson
and with two outs after the single in
the hit batter he punches out the reds
catcher and it stays a 5-1 game
you certainly want to win each series
but i think
in that clubhouse they talk about how
they were able to extend the season last
year
they can do it again
how about some runs
[Applause]
you're talking about face and joy of
otto and i was fortunate enough to be
able to strike him out a few times i
always felt if he got o2
if you threw a good commanded fastball
like that you could do that right there
at 97 and he gets bottle looking and
that is that
one two three go the reds out of the six
cubs lead
[Music]
young players trying to take the next
step in development jeff hoffman on here
pitching change brought to you by
lakeside bank that's hit pretty well
right field way back there gone
from one alcantara to another sergio
goes yard his third
and it's 6-1
fastball out over the middle of the
plate does not miss it absolutely
tattoos that ball to right field last of
the six
ready payoff pitch
and that's on the ground duffy will take
it in
and over to schwendell for the third out
good job manny rodriguez a pair of
scoreless innings
you know because then you're asking for
trouble putting two guys on absolutely
on the ground softly hit alcantara to
bodhi and that ends the inning good job
roe wick pitches around a one-out walk
we're heading to the eighth
and the cubs lead 6-1
i don't know if it's arm action or what
but get a lot of swing and miss a lot of
chase down and away on that pitch
like right there struck him out and adam
morgan
more quality work they go one two three
we're headed to the ninth and the cubs
lead at six one
jose barrero with gloves skills
well i mentioned this kid is a shortstop
and it's really the only play he has
because of how close he is
this one butted first base side
everybody's safe run is in
and the cubs and one more single rbi 7-1
a heads-up play from matt duffy but over
the long stretch over a lifetime if you
do the right things most of the time
you'll reap that harvest
jose barrero
first career big league extra base hit
nice adjustment on that breaking ball
see the little pause hesitation
check swing did he go yes he did
struck him out ball game and the cubs
win it
mcgill finishes it off